this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app mmm you
want to get paid $5.00 of course you do
why wouldn't you it's money and you want
to also give five dollars to charity of
course you do because you good person
all right
you want to buy and sell Bitcoin
instantly or get your paycheck deposited
right into the app yeah we all like
instant money well then you got to
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android it's the number one finance app
in the App Store and we all use it here
at the congradulations studios so
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now 60 whoa it's episode 60 we
got episode 60 going here I didn't know
I had like I keep saying and like I said
before and like I said we'll say again I
had no idea that we'd be in episode 60 I
thought maybe we'd be a 14 or whatever
but you know daddy got a [ __ ] haircut
a little bit and when when daddy gets a
haircut all of his friends say oh you
got a haircut and then I say yeah that's
as far as that conversation ever goes by
the way well you got a haircut huh yeah
Wow looks good cool that's as far as it
ever goes you might as well say loo loo
loo and then the other guy and then you
go whooping another guy goes cuz it's
all what it is and it mean it means
nothing you know I used to have a thing
where and I guess I still think about
this but like if you wear red shoes it
doesn't matter what the [ __ ] they are
people will just be like ah nice shoes
because they'd they're out of the
ordinary and they don't even mean nice
shoes they just mean oh those shoes are
red that's exactly what they mean when
they say when they see red shoes and
they say hey cool shoes what they mean
is though she's a red if they were
another color they wouldn't be that cool
right it's still the same literally the
same shoe but the color is making them
say hey cool shoes
ekoo des hommes just cuz the shoes red
is cool what if it was [ __ ] black you
wouldn't say that you might think that
but you wouldn't say it
you killed um I got uh yeah Deb I got a
little bit of a haircut and every time
I'd go to get my hair cut and if I put
out like on my histogram story people be
like no like hair doesn't grow back or
or like I don't know like I'm gonna
shave it dude I've had the same haircut
for [ __ ] 15 years it's gonna be fine
also it's just hair and also the older
we get the more we lose anyway see you
later
but yeah I butters jumping up on that
[ __ ] orange couch man killing it
hey B what's up B he always looks at me
so insecure dude every time I look at
butter she's always like looking at me
like did I do something wrong dude I
don't hit ya I give you a little bit of
pop on the [ __ ] nose if you if you
piss on the curtains like you tried to
do the other day dude these [ __ ] dogs
man they know right from wrong
and they if I sleep too late sometimes
they'll go [ __ ] in the bathroom at least
they use the bathroom you know that's
respectable see that's how I know that
they know what to do cause it'd be like
well I can't can't [ __ ] near him cuz
then when I first got the dogs they [ __ ]
the bed
like the [ __ ] Saint they literally
[ __ ] in my bed while I was in it and I
said no a bunch of times and now they go
to the bathroom to do it when it when
they're you know when I sleep too late
which is a lot of the time I sleep too
late kiss em comedian I was at the
Comedy Store had to follow Sebastian a
bunch of times this past weekend always
dislike and enjoy following him because
he is he's a killer and and he but it's
fun to follow him cuz it's fun it's fun
to try and [ __ ] get the crowd going
after somebody who kills I I don't
understand a lot of comedians will try
and jockey their position so they don't
have to follow a killer I like following
killers because it makes keeps you
surfers or keeps you sharp and second of
all it's really hard to do and if you do
it you feel good and if you don't do it
then [ __ ] it you're like alright it
wasn't my night that guy [ __ ] killed
it was his night it's fine you're not
gonna be the best every single time I
know guys I
comedians there are comedians out there
that just like if they're on a show they
don't want other [ __ ] hard-hitting
comedians on that show because they want
to be the best and that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's some [ __ ] straight-up
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude when I'm on a show I
won't Rogen I want Sebastian I want
Bilborough I won't [ __ ] Chris Rock to
show up I want all that [ __ ] dude it's
[ __ ] I want to be the guy I want to
be the underdog I want to be I want to
be the guy who people are like oh this
[ __ ] guy we got to watch this guy now
we were just in between - we were
watching everybody kill and now we gotta
watch this [ __ ] guy and then I
[ __ ] you know what I'm talking about
and then I do the [ __ ] DJ Khaled song
of course I don't have it cued up you
know actually maybe I still have it in
my how about the [ __ ] in the dude my
favorite meme is this one dude when the
[ __ ] guy like is gonna go fall down
and then as he's as he's falling down he
go instead of falling down he goes
[ __ ]
he just goes [ __ ] blasting into outer
space right here it's so funny that
[Music]
songs already funny dude
how about the [ __ ] thing did you ever
see the guy the the the video online
reads like where the guy does the skater
skate move and the guy goes like that
was legitness
do you ever see that one the Google that
anyway I remember when I was in [ __ ]
elementary school yeah I thought it was
cool to say coolness like a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] I thought it was cool to
say coolness I think I cuz I heard like
Parker Lewis say it on Parker Lewis
can't lose or maybe I maybe I don't even
know I don't even know if that's from
that but I remember had a crush on this
girl named rosemary I always had a and
she would wear it she would wear like
the I was in New Jersey and she'd wear
these [ __ ] all the girls would wear
these like the crewneck sweaters that
were like billowy and [ __ ] [ __ ] who's in
my class rosemary who else the girl
named hailey I had a crush on forever
and rosemary and Hailey were friends and
I had a crush on both of them and then
there was a girl named Oh
there was a girl named Yale I think and
this was the first [ __ ] baller move I
ever did this was the first baller move
I ever did when I was [ __ ] I was [ __ ]
oh I must have been in like fifth grade
people told me Yale had a crush on me
and then something went down where I was
like Yale was like being annoying or
something and I was like upset about it
and somebody was like well why is she
beat why do you think she's being
annoying and I said you want to [ __ ]
know and she said and they said yeah and
Yale was there and I said it's because
she likes me and has a crush on me and
she goes she says no I don't obviously
cuz you're in fifth grade not gonna
admit that and I said yeah you do that
was the [ __ ] birth
you know what I mean that was the
[ __ ] congratulations birth where I
was gonna stare directly in somebody's
eyes and [ __ ] call him out on that
[ __ ] and I was in fifth grade and I was
like stand by it and I said it [ __ ] me
up
cuz she was like no you don't and I was
like all right here I knew this was
gonna happen in my my heart and in my
head my heart started racing and I was
like oh you're gonna lie now in fifth
grade imagine me crouched and my [ __ ]
in my what was the clothing [ __ ] what
was that the [ __ ] I used to wear goddamn
I had this shirt I liked with handprints
on it I thought it was so dope like I
was in Color Me badd what the [ __ ] was
that shirt I have no idea but it what
no it wasn't body Glover body Glover
hyper colors those were also them you
know it might have not been that big I
might have just been a cool shirt but it
was it was a shirt where that was like
white white ish it was like off-white
and had blue hand prints on it let me
tell you right now
if I had that shirt now it would be
bonkers to it it would be the [ __ ]
illest shirt ever it wouldn't even fit
it'd be too small because I was after
the grade I still wear that [ __ ] with
some tight jeans oh man just looking
[ __ ] fancy as [ __ ] just look like I
[ __ ] guys for real and just be like
nah it's just been my favorite shirt you
[ __ ] me me me me and then start
[ __ ] guys in outer space man yeah
dude I [ __ ] put yell at her place
dude you need to start putting people in
their place it fit great bro
start early so people know how you are
so they're not surprised later right
that's what Trump did well nobody knew
he's not surprising anybody now right
he's not surprising [ __ ] the
guy's like guy [ __ ] a porn star while
he was married and and paid her to hush
up and we're like ah that's our crazy
president that's how you do it bro yeah
man childhood was [ __ ]
[ __ ] what a butt man who've grown up
in New Jersey was the [ __ ]
my best friend lived next door Matt
Ravenna did I used to get so scared in
my [ __ ] while I would sleep I would I
could never sleep over a person's my map
my imagination was crazy dude
I remember one time my mom and dad were
going on vacation and the car came to
pick him up for the airport and I saw
the guy who was picking him up for the
airport and immediately he had like
thinning hair but a lot like a ponytail
and it was pulled back and he had like a
nice you know blazer on because he was a
driver I guess and you know some car
service or some [ __ ] that they hired to
take him to the airport and he showed up
and I got so scared because to me he
looked like a villain and I had just
seen too many movies already but I was
like he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna
kill them on the way to the airport like
as a [ __ ] fourth grader I was like
that guy's gonna kill my parents because
of how he looks already prejudice his
[ __ ] as a fourth grader but I was like I
got a [ __ ] well I got a mitt I got to
make sure he doesn't do I gotta at least
warn my parents and I was like look
Chris you know they're gonna I didn't
even want them to go I was like he's
gonna kill him he's gonna [ __ ] murder
him and so I was like mom I said mom
come here and she came over and I said
be very careful because that guy looks
really like he looks like an evil guy
looks like a bad guy and I'm afraid he's
gonna kill you on the way to the airport
that was legitimately what I said to my
mom and she was like okay I'll be you
I'll be very careful and we'll make sure
that that doesn't happen
and I and it didn't happen you know they
whoever was watching me at the time
whoever stayed with me for a [ __ ]
week while they were in wherever they
were well you know told me your parents
landed safely and it's okay you know we
didn't have cell phones back then she
had to wait to [ __ ] in 17 hours until
you got a phone call and make sure
everybody's okay and and he didn't do it
and that that you know dude I would
[ __ ] I was in he I was an insane
[ __ ] as a kid there was a girl
that used to babysit us
Jojo her name was I didn't like the way
her mouth was you know her mouth was
like all like I don't know I don't
no I just decided I didn't like the way
her mouth was and she used this cup once
as when we were and and and and we had
different color cups like we had a
[ __ ] purple cup a clear cup a
greenish blue cup and a blue cup and a
[ __ ] pink cup and a pink and then
purple there were all like kind of like
versions of each other and then they had
a red there was a red cup and there were
like seven or eight of them it'd
probably have an even number because it
was a set and that was like the cups
that we would use you know and I
remember those [ __ ] cups so
vividly remember those [ __ ]
cups of vividly that sounds like it to
park there for about like a privileged
one anyway so Jojo used the first time
we had the cups and judge' came over she
used the [ __ ] greenish blue cup okay
and I decided that was gonna be her cup
forever so whenever she came to go
babysit us I was gonna [ __ ] make sure
if she wanted something to drink she was
gonna get the green Cup its greenish
blue Cup so if she was like I'm thirsty
and even if she went to go grab the pink
Cup I would be like here use this one
instead even though they washed the Cup
and I would tell my parents I could talk
about this because Ginger's definitely
dead now and even if she's not she's 90
and she doesn't listen to podcast and
even if she does she doesn't listen to
mine and and she [ __ ] she would she
would use that cup and I would tell my
parents I was like look my whenever my
mom would give it finally I was like I
don't want to tell my parents that I
don't want to use the cup cuz my parents
already thought I was crazy because I
have [ __ ] like crazy like I wanted
him to call me crazy legs like legit
legit Ness I wanted to call them to call
me
I wanted my parents to call me crazy
legs dude I asked my parents genuinely
hey will you call me crazy legs and they
said no I said at least at the dinner
table and my dad said no I named you
[ __ ] Chris you [ __ ] but I wanted
that I think I talked about this on
Rogen I don't know but anyway so I was
always like trying to hide my craziness
you know because I didn't want my
parents to think they had a [ __ ]
crazy kid so my [ __ ] mom finally once
supported the [ __ ] liquid that for me
whatever it was you know water or soda
or milk with the Ice Cube's clanking
around here it comes in the [ __ ]
greenish blue cup and I'm in my head I'm
like that's JoJo's cup I don't want her
[ __ ] mouth to touch something in my
mouth to touch something so now the
[ __ ] cup comes by and I was like my I
don't can you put it in a different cup
she says why and I said look I don't
want to get into it but that's JoJo's
cup and she's like what do you mean and
I said that's the cup that Jojo uses
every time she babysit come my mom
didn't know my mom didn't know because
she wasn't around when Jojo was around
she was somewhere else just like I
always look I always make sure that
that's JoJo's cup and that's JoJo's cup
and I want to use JoJo's Cup because you
know I don't like her mouth it's weird
and it does weird things and I don't
want her [ __ ] germs on my journal I
met in my mouth we wash the cups and I
said yeah but it doesn't matter he said
you know when you wash a cup in a
dishwasher it gets it uses really hot
water and soap knows like yeah but I did
some germs floating around she says it
all gets mixed up anyway in the
dishwasher I said I don't can you give
me the pink cup or some [ __ ]
and so she pour it out and put all right
we gotta use dude you can't keep Chris
JoJo's cup that was always the joke
right can't give Chris JoJo's [ __ ]
cup so then they'd give me the pink Cup
or the purple Cup and nobody else cared
if they had the judges Cup and I was
like I [ __ ] you know that's you yes
your own [ __ ] fear your funeral and
then and then and then [ __ ] sometimes
they didn't know they didn't know they
didn't respect it is the thing they
didn't respect my way to thinking cuz
they knew I was being a peep you know
like all ridiculous which I understand I
was being ridiculous and I'm not like
that now I would drink out at any cup
whatever but like they were trying to
get they would be like here's the cow we
don't here's the cup that Chris likes
and it would they would give me the
[ __ ] blue blue green cup and but they
thought that Joe because the blue Cup
the blue-green cup looked it was like
very similar and to be like don't give
Chris JoJo's cup and they'd be like
that's the blue one I be like MA
there's definitely [ __ ] blue and blue
green JoJo's Cup was the blue-green Cup
I would imagine a [ __ ] nine year old
just like guys sit down JoJo's Cup is a
blue-green Cup I don't want to use
George's Cup because I don't like the
way her mouth is and she puts I make
sure every time she babysits I was like
a little [ __ ] Stalin and I never used
[ __ ] JoJo's Cup I ever ever we got
rid of those cups obviously we don't
still have them because it's a [ __ ]
century later you know what I wish right
now
I had [ __ ] judge Oz cop I wish that
was you know they say you know you
become what you hate well that's I wish
I had JoJo's Cup that will be my cup
from now on I would conquer that [ __ ]
oats OCD thought or that that [ __ ]
thought and I'd make that cup my cup
dude I feel like we all had [ __ ] like
that as a little kid but I that [ __ ] got
worse for me like I have crazy [ __ ]
thoughts I remember one time we had this
babysitter I can't remember her name she
was French and she was like hot she was
like a hot babysitter and one time what
the [ __ ] was her name she was like this
blonde French hot babysitter
we're always get like he's [ __ ]
French or like Brazilian babies like
what the [ __ ] did they come from we were
New Jersey they'd be like hi we're here
to watch the kids get cake and get
kicking it oh we we I am here towards
the kids and I was like getting [ __ ]
I was just getting boners and [ __ ] one
of them was like named Maria but one of
them was blonde and and I had heard this
is a real [ __ ] story I had heard that
French babysit I heard that the French
people had like nude beaches god this
[ __ ] babysitter must I mean in my
head she is older than me right but I'm
37 and oh I mean she's definitely older
than me but like but like in my head
while she was babysitting even in my
memory she's older than me so I'm
imagine her as 45 this girl was like
[ __ ] 18 you know
she's 19 or 20 she's probably so hot but
as a [ __ ] seven-year-old and my my
brother was probably five and I was
probably I was nine
right cuz my brother's for using of me
sounds like I was like to my brother's
like you know they have new beaches in
France let's try to get her just show
like it's not a big deal to show us or
her boobs
and I was like we were watching TV and I
was like like just picture me just being
all like [ __ ] like in a in a you know
like a cool ass hat with like a suit on
even though I was just in like a t-shirt
and boxers probably picking my nose
drinking hi-c and I was like hey you
know they have their nude beaches in
France right and she was like oh yeah
you know like we we we cannot we have
nude beaches it is not a big deal in
America we cannot we have you have to
cover up but it's not a big deal and I
was in my head I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] finagle is to see some [ __ ] and
debts as a nine year old you know I'm
gonna try to see some boobs I was like
well yes it's not a big deal here either
people make it a big deal but it's not
she's like I yeah and my brother was
just quiet as [ __ ] you know like what
the [ __ ] I can't believe what Chris is
trying to pull with his little ball
haircut like [ __ ] Jim Carrey and dumb
and dumber and then she was like yeah I
was like if it's not the big days I
cannot touch him she was like I guess if
your mom wouldn't think I was like yeah
she doesn't care and I and I and I and I
think I asked to see him first right and
she lifts him up and she pulled her
[ __ ] tits out dude
I was [ __ ] 8 and she pulled her boobs
out I mean you know I was [ __ ] at the
most I was 11 at the most because we
moved when I was 12 so and I was like
ever
time I saw boobs in real life and then
my brother I don't even remember what he
was doing but he was just sitting
staring on just like my brother was
lucky cuz he get to see boobs in his
life for the first time at five bro this
is how I was trying to help my [ __ ]
brother right and then I was like can I
touch him and she was like as long as
your mom wouldn't care I was like yeah
yeah she's like cool how the [ __ ] was I
doing
how the [ __ ] was I like manipulating the
situation as like a ten-year-old like a
ten year old [ __ ] it's a guy's name
who [ __ ] Dietrich the writer who
[ __ ] got Hitler involved Dietrich
[ __ ] I don't know the [ __ ] guy was
who [ __ ] got Hitler into the Nazi
Party
Dietrich he didn't trick I meet Dietrich
Eckart Eckhart Dietrich Eckart that's
who I was like some little German
[ __ ] nine-year-old trying to get
Hitler involved to the Nazi Party to use
as my [ __ ] plan to [ __ ] take I was
like just kind of II see her boobs
mm-hmm and she was like yeah as long as
her mom doesn't get yes we don't care
she has cooled let us see and she showed
us and then and then she was like and
then she was like showed me the rose and
I said can I touch down and she was like
as long as your mom doesn't care yeah
she's cool and then she and then she was
like okay and she pulled her boob out
and I went I literally went like this
like where you cup it under Anna
hubba-hubba it like I didn't like caress
it like I'm [ __ ] nice gentle man I
[ __ ] like jiggled it like like I like
how a cartoon would do it because I
didn't know anything and I remember I
did it and then I went like this
afterwards I would did it and I went II
like a [ __ ] like like oh gross girls
and like I even even as a nine-year-old
when I did that I in my head I thought
oh that was gay I did that
you know like oh why am i acting like I
don't like it
or like I'd like it you know even as a
nine-year-old I was like I don't want
her to think I'm gay or not gay but like
cuz I didn't know about gay yet but like
a femme like feminine you know I didn't
want it I want her to think I was a real
man as a [ __ ] 10 year old I was
thinking this and then and then
wow that's [ __ ] so funny but I
[ __ ] Dietrich Eckart her accorded her
and she was my Hitler and then she never
babysat us again because my brother I
told my brother was like listen don't
tell mom and dad because we got like two
hookups now we got the [ __ ] dope
babysitter and she's gonna combine
source of [ __ ] boobs every time my
brother's like hired I won't tell and
then [ __ ] he they told her he told
them and of course she did [ __ ]
babies anymore and I was like Matt
you're [ __ ] up my yo you're [ __ ]
up my my my girl situation brah anyway
dude she [ __ ] I'll tell you what that
babysitter used any cup she wanted and I
[ __ ] use I use her right after I
didn't give a [ __ ] she was she was
slamming all right here we go
tripping did you know that the average
family visits five totally different
websites before booking a vacation
rental well that's ridiculous
okay I use this this thing called
tripping and you use it and it doesn't
what it does is you can spend less time
planning your next trip and more time
relaxing with tripping calm it's the
world's number one site for vacation
rentals tripping calm is trusted by
millions of travelers and featured by
New York Times Travel and Leisure with
trippin with trippin calm onesearch lets
you filter compare and sort over ten
million available properties on trusted
sites like VRBO verbo TripAdvisor
booking calm and more so it saves me
time and I've used it to book my trips
because otherwise you're just taking too
much time doing it and you're like
comparing
you get the two different when you have
the two different or three or four
different like pages up and you're like
what am I looking this does that for you
and so it's why I like it don't wonder
if you're getting the best deal you'll
save an average of 18% per night by
booking your vacation with trippin comm
it's worth it don't forget if you want
to save time and money while booking the
perfect vacation rental for your next
trip head to trippin dot-com / Congrats
today that's T RI PP ing dot-com /
Congrats
trippin dot-com / Congrats square cash
hmm look if you haven't heard which
means you're a Dumbo because you
listened to this podcast an episode 60
60 isn't the first podcast of mine
you've listened to we are all switching
to the couch we've already done it me
one fire and one get rid of that's what
I'm gonna start calling the second one
are switching to we all switch to the
cash up he's Russian or whatever that
would be
get rid of get rid of it's the simplest
way to pay people back friends family
you can pay one fire back one get rid of
back anyone okay you can pay dogs back
if they have a cell phone
setting and receiving money is totally
free and fast and most payments can be
deposited directly into your bank
account in just a few seconds and did
you know that cash out lets you do way
more than that now you can even buy and
sell Bitcoin instantly get your paycheck
deposited right to the app pull money
out of the ATM with the free custom cash
card or use it to spend anywhere you
like you really won't find a more useful
finance app out there you really want
I've used a bunch of them and I've
settled on this one and of course when
you download the cash app five dollars
goes to you and five dollars goes to the
times up Legal Defense Fund which is a
really important cause to me one fire in
one get rid of download the free cash
app for iOS or Android now yeah it
talked a lot about my childhood it's
crazy the way stuff shapes you and all
that you know I think about that I do I
think about this the way stuff shapes
you and the way stuff shapes people and
how everything is nobody's fault because
of
the way they were brought up by the
[ __ ] people that brought them up
basically whose fault it was was the
first two people they [ __ ] everything
up they ruined bringing up other people
and then those people kept on running
and as time went on everyone just got so
[ __ ] up i mean kim jeong-hoon who's in
the guy now we came Jong hoon Kim
jong-il before him right and before him
who was it it's gonna get worse and
worse because they keep [ __ ] up their
offspring you know we all [ __ ] each
other up and we all with Tupac said I'm
the product of the environment that rate
that [ __ ] made me and he's right
he's right it's not somebody's fault
it's crazy right especially because some
people's minds are just [ __ ] broken I
mean they lock people up who do heroin
in jail you know that's [ __ ] weird
they got a real problem in there just
gonna lock him the [ __ ] up I don't know
look I'm not saying I know what to do I
think I know a little bit about what not
to do just because purse but like yeah
people get so [ __ ] up and then they
become 70 and there's no change in them
here's the deal I was at a coffee shop
two days ago and I was not paying
attention there was somebody in front of
me I was waiting for them now they were
taking entirely too long and it's
because there were a 70 year old woman
they wasn't 70 she was probably 55 nah
she probably 60 now she was taking
entirely too long and it wasn't because
she was an old lady it was because she
was a an annoying person that's why you
knew when this woman was 25 she was
still the kind of person that took too
long it wasn't the kind of thing where
you're like old lady yep she was just
like it's like yeah you're taking too
long
because you don't give a [ __ ] about
anybody else so she was taken too long
and I was told I was busy I was what he
called it not paying attention and I was
facing the other way and I
turned around and I and I bumped her a
little bit with my shoulder I mean I
didn't even bumper I brush her it wasn't
a bump I wouldn't say it was a bump it's
like a Seinfeld episode was it a bump or
a brush it was a brush and I and I
turned around I said oh this is exactly
how I said I said I'm so sorry I wasn't
paying attention and she looked and she
just went like huh you know so I stepped
further away from her I was about to at
least two feet from her now now I was I
was more than two feet from her she kept
looking back 30 at least 30 seconds went
by she kept kind of looking back as she
was figuring out what to get first of
all it was taking too long already and
now she's taking way too long
and she kept looking back me as I'm a
[ __ ] is she looking back at me it was
very weird and now I was paying
attention and 30 / 30 seconds goes by
and then she looks back at me finally
the last time and she says could you
please not bump into me again and I look
at her and I just start laughing because
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
lady
first of all way too much time went by I
stepped back over two feet like what was
i planning 200 and then after the
[ __ ] thing she was waiting for her Oh
God
she was waiting for her drink just like
and she was going like this like rubbing
it like I [ __ ] beat her at
and then she kept [ __ ] like looking
at me and then like and then and then
other and then and then I realized that
she was a little bit like weird because
she kept on like looking at other people
talking them for no reason but like
either her mind is broken or she was
raised so wrong that ship is [ __ ] up
and it's not even her fault but I wanted
to get mad at her I mean obviously I
didn't say anything
just gives a [ __ ] and I'm trying to be
as normal as I can she was but it was so
weird imagine how many [ __ ] weird
JoJo's Cup story she has and her
childhood you know god I was reading
this book called come here and it was
about the guy who ran American
University I think isn't like DC or
something I don't know but he was having
all sorts of like weird thoughts about
like being attracted to children and he
didn't any and he was trying to trace it
back why and it was because he realized
that like his mom and dad molested him
and yeah what was it like yeah
Washington DC the book is called to come
here I read it and it's [ __ ] up a man
overcomes the tragic aftermath of what
is it yeah of childhood sexual abuse
anyway he was starting to like it's
really really interesting because the
guy like like overcame it and didn't
molest anybody but like understood that
he wanted to he had those that
inclination and he got I think he got he
resigned from that cuz he was he was
like starting to like I think email or
something college kids and he was just
realizing it was inappropriate and then
just resigned and then wrote this book
Richard burr ends and anyway it was a
good book and it was really interesting
I have no [ __ ] idea why I read it
like what the [ __ ] but uh it was
interesting because that it was like
that it's like the cycle you know but
that's that's what it is though like you
think I'm not gonna have [ __ ] kids
that aren't weird that they have like I
don't want to use [ __ ] our
babysitter's cup and then I'm just gonna
be like yeah I get it [ __ ] for [ __ ]
sake I told you my own cause two wallets
it runs on my [ __ ] family by the way
did I read the [ __ ] email that my
uncle sent me on on-air number one I
talking to Ari I gotta read this [ __ ]
what what yeah he sent me an email
no no no he didn't even send me an email
he sent the [ __ ] podcast an email on
my website he's got my number he's my
uncle [ __ ] Vinny oh god what is that
Vinny I probably don't there we go why
can you never look at the mail in the
[ __ ] of course still searching and
find there it is oh wait no because it
wasn't from him it was from [ __ ] one
fire dad I gotta find the [ __ ] I mean
so far back he sent one fire sent me the
[ __ ] email and he just wrote I mean
and then let me see if I could find it
cause it's really funny because this is
all [ __ ] up my family is well you know
what what what episode was that that we
talked about it I guess we don't know
huh I'm trying to look at
not gonna find this for [ __ ] sake well
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna okay
wallet if I just put wallet in the
search thing it should show up right all
right here we go got it here it is all
right so one fire sent me this this is
two so all right so for those of you
that didn't listen the episode which I'm
probably a lot of you did but my oh this
is why this is why I'm so [ __ ] up cuz
this is what my family does okay so so
my so I talked about how my uncle has
two wallets my uncle Vinny has two
[ __ ] wallets he keeps ones in one and
keeps other money in there and I forgot
that he you know I'm just gonna read the
email I was making fun of him why he
keeps two wallets and how far could
ridiculous isn't ridiculous it is and
how my family always makes fun of him
for it and then he always tries to
explain why all right
it was bald-faced a lot barefaced lie
that's what that was because he's all
right so here's here's oh and I talked
to you I talked also about the digestive
drink I refer to is Underberg about how
like you overeat remember I was talking
about that you overeat and then you take
the Underberg and you feel better anyway
this is the focus on my uncle I guess he
listens to the I know he listens to some
of the podcasts and I guess he heard
this one or maybe somebody does it maybe
somebody whom he knows alerted him to it
because uh all right so here we go so he
emails first of all the website the the
podcast website not me
he has my number he doesn't call me
doesn't text me he he knows it's gonna
go to the [ __ ] one fire subject first
of all it's from his [ __ ] a law firm
email address email address
alright subject to wallets slash
Underberg that's the subject okay
message I respect
[ __ ] lunatic he is I respectfully
submit that you are a bold bald
barefaced liar I have two wallets and
two money clips alright if you put all
your money credit cards health cards ID
cards driver's license etc in one wallet
you are walking around with a wallet the
size of the Manhattan phonebook
alright with two what it's hard to argue
that yeah that it's true is a lot of
[ __ ] to put in one wallet alright he's a
really good arguing he's a [ __ ]
lawyer okay with two wallets evenly
distributed in back pockets I achieve
buttock balance and comfort as to the
two money clips in parentheses in two
different front pocket front pockets
just imagine we are hanging out one day
and one thing leads to another and we
wind up at a strip I am prepared with $1
bills you are not go to strip clubs
second of all we're not gonna go when
the strip club valet in parentheses
entitled to its hip returns my car I
have the singles to tip him and you look
like a cheap alright next suppose we get
mugged I give the mugger my singles
money clip and a wallet with she does
not know about my more valuable money
clip or my more valued wallet i
minimized my loss but you in parentheses
one wallet with all your money credit
cards etc in it are left penniless and
there is a greater likelihood that the
muggers will beat the crap out of you
because you
too stupid to have two wallets money
clips or how does that make sense and
there's a greater likelihood whatever
furthermore the quote unquote digestive
drink you refer to is called Underberg
it is made from herbs and bitters and
has been selling worldwide for over a
hundred fifty years in parentheses that
is before you were born and I never said
that you should overeat and then take
Underberg so you can overeat some more I
will admit however that it's not a bad
idea I will let you know tomorrow so let
this message serve as a formal notice
that you are to immediately that you're
to immediately cease and desist from
your unauthorized slanderous comments
about me and if you cannot do both then
at least desist or cease whatever is
easier love uncle Vinnie oh I [ __ ]
love my family man of course
I forwarded this to the rest of my
family and my dad [ __ ] email you back
I'm crying and I I assumed it was
because I assumed something it was soon
because he was crying laughing but now
that I think about it it's probably
because that has to be his brother [ __ ]
how do you grow up not crazy
and I'm not saying I'm crazy like
obviously but like how do you grow up
not affected by that [ __ ] lunacy my
family my parents my uncle Richard my
uncle Vinnie my aunts man
I was with them yesterday some of my mom
my parrot minima and I put up an
Instagram video of us but all we do is
talk [ __ ] and laugh about it it's so far
canned it feels so healthy man I [ __ ]
I'm real fortunate man and and I and I
try not to take it for granted you know
my dad's gonna be 70 in a few days and
[Music]
it's just uh it's just uh you know I
guess I suppose that's where I was
thinking about my childhood lately
because I've been I've been thinking
about all the times that I've had with
them and [ __ ] and like how great it is
and how much like [ __ ] love is there
man like like doing that [ __ ] like they
they're packing up their [ __ ] and
they're there they're moving and you
know my dad would be annoying his [ __ ]
was just like you got to help us pack
before the [ __ ] movers get here which
is like what the [ __ ] he getting the
movers for you know and I'm driving down
to the beach just all [ __ ] it's so
far and [ __ ] and I get there you know
maybe in my 20s I would have been like
why the [ __ ] do I have to do this but I
got there and I was just nice to spend
time with him and make fun of him and be
made fun of and [ __ ] show love that
way that's how we do it and it was it
was just I put up some video of an
Instagram because I don't know I think
my family's relatable and [ __ ] I guess
but they we had a good time we're just
laughing and [ __ ] make fun of each other
calling each other [ __ ] but yeah I
don't know I you know that's why I was
thinking about my childhood and I I
don't think I consciously wanted to talk
about it on my podcast it wasn't in my
notes or anything but you know your
parents get older and you got a [ __ ]
you know or not even just parents people
get older and you got a yeah I don't
want to be one of those corny
[ __ ] it's like cherish the time
you have all your [ __ ] parents or
people are on the earth and while your
the earth but it's like who who cares my
brother would say you're gonna die
anyway what's it matter but you know
it's it's it's cool to think about [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] that's [ __ ] right that's
all we have pictures and [ __ ] and
memories that's so [ __ ] I forget so
much [ __ ] people remind me [ __ ] I'm like
really that happened and they're like
yeah last Tuesday's I got [ __ ] I wish I
remember that because that sounds
awesome
did somebody take a [ __ ] snapchat of
it yeah mm-hmm yeah I was I was in
therapy once for years just like you
know going because I thought it was a
good idea just to keep mentally healthy
and one thing that my [ __ ] therapist
said and I always think about this is
you know she was talking about when her
payment parents died and she was talking
about how it's the worst thing you go
through and the only good part about it
is and this is what [ __ ] me up the
only good part about your parents dying
is that you never have to do it again
you never have to go through it again
and that's crazy there's so few things
like that hopefully cuz like look other
things don't happen to people like don't
don't happen to everybody like you know
people's some people's kids get murdered
but it doesn't happen to everybody some
people get [ __ ] raped that doesn't
happen to everybody of course it's great
that that doesn't ever have to happen
again if it happens to you but but it
still could you know if you have more
kids or [ __ ] you're in the wrong area
wrong time but your parents never die
twice and that's the only [ __ ] thing
that's good about that that's [ __ ]
crazy
that's stuck with me a lot and I [ __ ]
think about that all the time I don't
mean to get all
serious dude but man that's gotta be the
[ __ ] I don't know like I love my
parents so much that's gonna be [ __ ]
anyway I don't wanna think about that
supposed to be a comedy podcast Jesus
Christ you know what though seriously
you guys got a [ __ ] we got it we got
to get through everything man it can't
just be [ __ ] Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
comedy all the time it you got to take
some dips you got to [ __ ] him come
with me dude
this is a cult you're not it is not a
podcast this is a cult we're joking
we're laughing we're having a good time
and then we get [ __ ] we get real
because not because we try to or it's by
design just because that's what happened
this is the ebb and the flow of
conversation and the and the cult man
when we're in the log cabin later on I
can't we can't there's gonna be times
there's gonna be hard times there's
gonna be times where people get you know
don't get along people get you know
people are gonna die people are gonna
thrive and be happy but people are also
gonna hurt their knee and then we got a
[ __ ] aw [ __ ] get it
rub it get an ice pack and is your okay
you know this is what we're preparing
you for life
[ __ ] college dude that doesn't do [ __ ] I
mean it does some stuff but like you
know this is real [ __ ] dude and dude I
need you I know I'm the cult leader but
I need you [ __ ] I really do
dude I need you to spread the [ __ ]
word and help our cause and leave live
this hedonistic lifestyle and get [ __ ]
and sucked back to comedy this guy last
year
here you know what am I saying dude last
week like I just say [ __ ] it last week
the elder and
he did this CUDA song Ritchie put what
is it bridge sheep let pallies right
yeah he did this CUDA song I don't know
if you guys heard it but I'm gonna play
a little a bit of it this [ __ ] is
brilliant
[Music]
that's a beautiful so far yeah
and when you serve
[Music]
cool
you're
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's big
oh we
and wearing bibs and buying please
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful song listen to that beautiful
sound listen to that beautiful sound
listen to that beautiful another son
inside me but a baby's car is truly
country
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah dude that [ __ ] song Jesus Christ
it's so funny the first time I heard it
I was [ __ ] laughing so hard
Jesus Christ it makes me emotional a
little bit wider [ __ ] does that happen
[Music]
half for [ __ ] sake Jesus Christ makes
me want to [ __ ] cry a little bit
because it's true you know there's
[ __ ] yeah it's hard to [ __ ] hmm B
and it's hard to not it's hard to not uh
not be CUDA you know I mean I know it's
funny and [ __ ] but it's [ __ ] true
that song is pretty and he's just
emotional about [ __ ] people being
Cudas I appreciate that man I was
thinking too you know it was funny what
else I remember from from going to
therapy was uh you know you're there for
for therapy and you're there to help me
to get your you shouldn't have the
person help you and all that [ __ ] or
whatever at least talk some [ __ ] out and
I I me though you know and like I when
I'm you know I make fun of [ __ ] and all
that so I'd like sometimes give her [ __ ]
and ask her stuff like about her even
her life or the room and [ __ ] and she
never really you know talked too much
about it but there was this stupid
[ __ ] there were these figurines that
were holding hands but they were
individual right like you could move
them however you wanted and they were
holding each other's hands or touching
you know it was supposed to be like and
they were all from different backgrounds
like the people more some were darker
than others and some were [ __ ]
Swedish and [ __ ] and you know they tried
to there were maybe like
ten of them and they were all set up and
one of them didn't have an arm right
like because it broke not because it
didn't and I said to I was like why is
that I was like there's not an arm there
what the [ __ ] happened is like is that
supposed to be like the disabled one and
she laughed and she was like nah she's
like it actually pisses me off I said
how come and she said well because when
I moved into this office I I dropped one
of them and the the arm came off and so
I would set that when I set them up I
set them up but I put the arm down next
to the one without the arm that broke
off and it was like that for a while
until one of my clients or patients said
hey that arm is broken I noticed I I
fixed stuff like this all the time
I can I can take that for you and I have
the glue at home and I can just put put
it good as new and it won't and it'll
look normal and so she so she said okay
and she took the [ __ ] thing back and
when she came back the next week for
therapy she came back with the figurine
without the arm and she said I'm so so
so sorry
but I I not only didn't fix it I lost
the arm I don't know where it is
and the therapist was like oh well you
know try to make her not feel bad that's
okay I you know it's alright but it did
upset anyway she said to me says and it
always really upset me because every
time I look at it I know I had the arm
and now I don't have it and I probably
have done it myself and I just bums me
out that that's not there because this
these figurines she got like on a trip
somewhere years ago that really meant
something to her and all that [ __ ] and I
said yeah that's um that's true you
could you could be really upset about
that but also like that's
I said something like that's what's
supposed to happen like you know you got
those [ __ ] figurines and you enjoyed
them as much as you could with the arm
and then you dropped it and you lost and
you thought somebody was gonna help you
and they [ __ ] lost the arm themselves
and they brought the arm they brought
the thing back without the arm and now
it doesn't have an arm but that's what
was supposed to happen and now you have
the story about that and you had the guy
with the arm for a long time and that
was the time that you were supposed to
have with that and that was the time
that was supposed to you should you
should you know to be corny again
cherish the [ __ ] full figurine set
you were lucky to have that for that
amount of time and now he doesn't have
the arm and it's kind of funny that that
happened that you brought the [ __ ]
person back and it came back without the
arm and now you have a story about it
and and and that's what those figurines
are to you now the [ __ ] guy without
the arm he's almost the most important
one now and she said yeah yeah you're uh
you're actually right you made me feel
better about that and and I said I
wouldn't even want that arm back if you
had it to put glue it because that's
what that's what it is now you know and
she was like yeah and I could tell I get
it like not that I made her feel better
but like I thought but she's like I
didn't think of it that way like you're
right you know and because like I don't
know I was I was watching I was also in
a good
during this guy's the doctor I think I
was in the I was in episodes as I was
watching it and the guy was paralyzed
and they were like we could fix it and
you can be unparallel okay and then the
wife didn't want him to because she's
like I love you like this you know and
it's like a [ __ ] you know whatever
happens happens and you roll with the
punches and [ __ ] and I guess that's why
I was thinking about that therapist
thing because I was thinking about like
you know everything goes away anyway so
you should [ __ ] be present I guess
and enjoy the time he had in the
memories and [ __ ] whatever I can't
believe what I'm [ __ ] talking about
but I do have these [ __ ] thoughts too
I'm not just a lunatic and a [ __ ] and
a piece of [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about
everything but anyway I was with my
family and I was helping them pack up
and move so I guess that's why I'm in
this [ __ ] kind of poignant thing but
I'm glad you guys are listening and it's
been a [ __ ] hour already that was
kind of quick but [ __ ] that Kudus
song man so funny I mean he did there
was one or two things that I didn't even
remember that I didn't remember on those
things let's take some quitter quest
Twitter questions though okay Wow I
thought you'd appreciate this
Stephanie Foss says at Miss Foss the
boss change it to year old referred to
her coat pockets as snack holes and this
is what I shall forever call them all
right look if you're too you can call
them snack holes but don't that's not
cute if you're an adult and you're like
hey [ __ ] yeah these are my snack
holes yeah you know what you get to do
you know what I do run your pockets
[ __ ]
give me you give me whatever the [ __ ] is
in your pockets now it's mine what
celebrities have told you that they
listen to your podcast that surprised
you Luke
Keating Keating Luke there have been a
few and I can't remember which is how
much of a [ __ ] PC should I am there
was some oh oh oh you know who told me
is Josh
he's probably listening right now I hope
he's listening I hope he still listens
but yeah my buddy Josh he my buddy Josh
dun who is a [ __ ] awesome and I don't
know if he listens to it with his with
his bandmate but he listens to it and I
like that dude and when I found out he
listened to it I was like sharks that
guy's a [ __ ] superstar and then who
else who else I can't really think about
it but sometimes I'm like on set and
people are like I listen your podcast
and [ __ ] actors and oh my god [ __ ]
really that's funny because then I get
embarrassed like I'm just talking in a
room I'm I don't get embarrassed but I'm
like a [ __ ] I wonder what I said there
that they like hooked onto that they
think I am now you know cuz I'm just
joking and being stupid and [ __ ] in a
room alone and I say [ __ ] is I'm gonna
[ __ ] I don't even know have to should
I say and like then [ __ ] like some
actor I'm gonna have to work with for
the next ten days it's like I listen to
your podcast do you really think that we
should all get [ __ ] by robots you know
and I'm like I have to talk to HR yeah
but anyway you guys are [ __ ] great
what else oh dude the oh I talked about
this on the [ __ ] I put that on the
Instagram that the [ __ ] poster for
the Avengers it's like what dude I put a
sea of people I was like guys between
these two posters dude how about how
[ __ ] crazy
it is the poster just have that the a
with the [ __ ] circle around it you
know we added nobody's going to as much
as I as much as I love Chris Evans and
[ __ ] you know Josh Brolin and [ __ ]
Scarlett Johansson nobody's going to see
that movie because of them and it's not
the knock on them they're great but
they're going to see the movie because
it's a [ __ ] spectacle and it's the
Avengers you know I have to put them all
on the poster
that's amigo [ __ ] that's so funny you
look at the poster there's people on
that that aren't even on the [ __ ]
thing I was like who is that [ __ ]
who's the [ __ ] fat asian guy
you know they only put him on there cuz
he's Asian and they wanted to [ __ ]
have the whole thing you know he's got
like two lines in the [ __ ] thing they
got a [ __ ] raccoon on it ah how about
that what was that one
Christopher Dennett at Chris underscore
dens did you da Vinci or you just make
up this [ __ ] thing it says making a
cup of coffee is an art you know what I
agree with that but here's the deal
here's what goes back to what I talked
about if you're gonna pick a job be
passionate about it and do it and make
it you alright but if you're talking
about how coffee is a big cup of coffees
aren't eat piece of [ __ ]
just do it feel good about it be
passionate about it but you know what
they're not making a documentary about
you okay you just make the coffee and
you feel good about it you don't need to
[ __ ] talk about how much it's a piece
of art because then whoa oh you're
getting into [ __ ] territory you're
getting into piece of [ __ ] territory
I'll do another one oh wow Wow
let me tell you something dude this guy
knows the vibe alright all you
[ __ ] ask me questions some of
them are stupid some of them you're just
trying to get my attention some of them
they're not things I want to answer some
of them I answer just to be fun and
funny but this [ __ ] this dude
knows the vibe okay this guy is in the
cult he probably had some
congratulations at him before the
podcast even started if not this guy's
doing the work okay
Matthew Heath at a some math you all
right well first of all he's got to I
didn't realize he had the s of Matthew
which is very cool this is a great
question dude Wow how [ __ ] is it to
chase after a bouncy ball
dude that guy nailed it let me tell you
something you know how [ __ ] it is the
most [ __ ] to chase after about
and to be like running after it and not
knowing which way it's gonna go and like
trying to grab it and missing it once
but having it [ __ ] pop off your hand
and then it alters the course of how its
bouncing and then you're running and
then it goes down on grass and you're
like oh hopefully it'll slow down on the
grass
you're the most [ __ ] ever if a girl
ever saw a dude that she was into a
little bit chasing after a bouncy ball
that's a [ __ ] rat dude you're not
making your dick wet Wow good job
Matthew Heath very you know how it is
the most [ __ ] round of applause for
Matthew Heath dude congratulations for
asking that [ __ ] question dude I love
that [ __ ] question because that's
something I never thought of but it's
[ __ ] true Wow dude we might have to
end on that [ __ ] beautiful question
man square cash have you switched yet
download the free square cash app enter
rewards code congrats get $5 and give $5
- times up
get it for iOS or Android now follow the
leader
second leg announcing soon we're
announced to get next Monday buy tickets
on crystally accom a lot of them are
sold out so once this second leg hits
you've got to get these tickets quick
because some of these showed out sold
out Tallahassee Florida Orlando sold out
Charleston first show sold out I added a
Late Show almost sold out Pittsburgh oh
I don't know if that sold out it
admitted to one or two tickets left
Dayton Ohio Huntsville Alabama Nashville
Tennessee Denver Colorado added a Late
Show Boise Idaho added a Late Show and
subscribe to the YouTube channel and
download the Krista Lea app for iOS or
Android you know what I think next time
I'm gonna get the app get my app because
next time I'm gonna go a little bit live
as we shoot the podcast for you guys
because I'm gonna go live on my app and
you guys are gonna hear congratulations
Pepa sewed 61 before anybody because
you're gonna hear it as it's happening
live
so download that out and make sure you
do it video episodes go up Tuesdays or
Wednesdays you got to watch my special
man on fire or incorrigible or right now
black comics
I'm gonna do some more episodes of alone
together coming up on the second season
I'm gonna be in at least three of those
I think I love doing that show it's
really funny if you haven't seen it
check it out even at resorts on not in I
[ __ ] love and I'm not in those so
that's a in the LA because I love myself
thanks for listening babies and remember
don't drink out of Jojo